[Musique]
on va parler maintenant de politique
puisqu'il risque de se passer une ou
deux choses importantes au cours de
cette année avec stéphane mon sens
bonjour bonjour patrice bonjour cher
patrice vous êtes vous êtes professeur
de droit public vous êtes ancien doyen
de la faculté de droit de l'université
de versailles saint quentin alors on va
pas parler des résultats de l'élection
présidentielle bien que vous les
connaissiez déjà mais voulait garder
secret un vous ne vous inquiétez pas je
les garde ses secrets je n'essaie de 4
avril
voilà bout mais on va on va essayer de
des d'analyser un peu ce qui se peut se
passer dans les prochains mois dans la
politique française d'abord un mou
peut-être sur cette élection
présidentielle au suffrage universel
voulue par le référendum voulu par le
général de gaulle c'est celle à
l'élection la plus importante de la vème
république
oui absolument on peut même dire que si
vous laissez là c'est vraiment la clé de
voûte des institutions de la vème
république
qui qui qui à l'origine sont quand même
comment dirais-je reconfigurer en 1958
pour restaurer l'autorité de l'état est
très clairement pour reconstruire un
nouveau régime essentiellement autour de
la figure de la figure dominante d'un
homme donc c'est très lié aux
circonstances le général de gaulle donc
le principe même est décidée en 1900 à
1960 de général de gaulle était lui en
1958 par un collège de grands électeurs
en 62
les français sont favorables à
l'élection au suffrage universel direct
qui pour la première fois a lieu en 1965
donc
hélas il ya parfois on entend quand même
quelques contestations sur ce système on
y reviendra peut-être dire et sur cette
élection au suffrage universel mais on a
l'impression quand même que ça serait
très difficile de revenir en arrière par
rapport à ça oui vous avez absolument
raison
le système fait l'objet alors parfois à
juste titre de critique qui sont quasi
permanente et qui sont récurrentes
depuis le début
souvenez vous souvenez vous du banc
fleix de françois mitterrand le coup
d'état permanent qui était très axé
alors non seulement sur la personne du
général de gaulle mais aussi sur 7 sur
ce principe de l'élection du président
par les français de manière directe
il ya eu quelques notamment une manière
assez récente quelque projet de vième
république ou n'est pas toujours
question de maintenir ce système mais je
pense fondamentalement lors jamais dire
jamais mais que au delà de tout ce qui
le peut être dit que les français sont
très attachés à cette à ce système de
l'élection directe du président les
français est en tout cas une partie
d'entre eux parce que alors si on
regarde un peu les les des études chez
des jeunes ils ont l'impression
qu'aujourd'hui les choses se passent
presque plus sur les réseaux sociaux que
dans les bureaux de vote et et
d'ailleurs il y aura même à cette
élection présidentielle qui pourtant
celle le à laquelle les deux français
participent le plus une abstention
importante des jeunes le chef oui alors
une abstention importante de manière
générale c'est pas impossible je vais
vous dire que si improbable je n'en sais
rien mais ça n'est pas impossible
une abstention plus prononcée du côté
des jeunes
j'allais vous dire là c'est un grand
classique on sait que les jeunes les
jeunes votent moins deux façon générale
il ya quelques exceptions et on suppose
qu'à ceux car ce scrutin qui aura lieu
dans trois mois les jeunes
s'abstiendront peut-être encore plus
mais c'est une illusion là là j'allais
dire la vraie vie c'est pas la vie des
réseaux sociaux la vraie vie c'est ce
qui se passe dans l'arène politique et
dans l'espace public alors le dire c'est
la clé de voûte des institutions de la
vème république il ya un mécanisme qui
ne s'est jamais démenti notamment alors
depuis l'inversion de ce qu'on a pas le
calendrier électoral c'est-à-dire que
des élections légistatives suit
l'élection présidentielle c'est que les
français donnent une majorité au
président qu'ils viennent d'élire est ce
que c'est une règle absolue est ce qu'on
pourrait pas imaginer au fond que ben on
revienne un peu une cohabitation est ce
que ça ne pourrait pas ce que il ya
peut-être moins d'élan dans la dans la
dans l'élection présidentielle elle même
qu'il y en ait eu par le passé oui il
faut préciser d'abord que sais tu
comment dirais-je cette inversion du
calendrier c'est à dire d'abord
l'élection présidentielle ensuite
l'élection législative
elle est justement été voulu pour éviter
les situations de cohabitation c'est à
dire situation les trois épisodes de
cohabitation chirac premier ministre de
mitterrand balladur premier ministre de
mitterrand et jospin premier need de
jacques chirac situation à laquelle le
premier et d'un bord politique opposé à
celui du président de la république
pourquoi est-ce qu'on a voulu éviter
parce qu'on s'est aperçu au cours de ces
trois périodes que au delà d'une espèce
de pseudo équilibre de d'équilibré des
pouvoirs si vous voulez à la tête de
l'état au sein de la dyarchie de l'état
de la tête de l'état il y avait en
réalité une bataille permanente entre
les deux têtes principal de de l'état
donc est-ce que c'est fondamentalement
une bonne chose que de cristalliser de
cette manière les élections législatives
et de les rendre dépendante de
l'élection présidentielle en terme
d'efficacité
oui sans aucun doute en termes de ré
inspiration politique en termes de marge
politique probablement nous et vous avez
raison rien n'est écrit après tout même
si ces deux scrutins ont lieu à deux ou
trois mois d'intervalle rien ne dit que
le président de la république qui sera
élu disposera d'une majorité solide à
l'assemblée enfin oui à l'assemblée
nationale pour autant est ce qu'il faut
j'allais dire revenir sur ce système ou
peut-être le nuancer
là encore je n'en suis pas sûr il faut y
aller prudemment j'avais certaines
propositions qui consistent à dire on
pourrait instaurer des élections
législatives en plein milieu du
quinquennat au bout de deux ans et demi
après l'élection présidentielle pour
remettre en quelque sorte les compteurs
à zéro là je suis pas sûr que les
français ils soient prêts ça nous
rapprocherait sur ce point de la
démocratie américaine est une démocratie
alors extrêmement
qui est doté d'une très forte vitalité
puisque tous les deux ans il ya des
élections majeures qui se déroule entre
les midterm élections donc ça veut dire
qu'on est en campagne électorale
permanente ça je suis pas sûr que les
que les français ils soient réellement
prêts et les mid term elections comme
vous dites sont rarement favorables au
président la puce bien sûr quelques avec
un système un système étasunien j'allais
vous dire c'est pas un problème parce
que le système est construit justement
sur 7 sur ses dissensions sur cette
tension notre système institutionnel lui
n'est pas configuré du moins pas pour
l'instant autour de 7,2 cette idée il ya
un petit point gros problème même
démocratique qui se poseront voit
combien un éparpillement au fond des
voix les candidats qui se sont
sélectionnés pour le deuxième tour son
art aux gros à plus ou moins 20 % 1 des
voix après évidemment ils sont élus à la
majorité
parce que selon votre contre le contre
l'autre candidat mais une fois qu'ils
veulent appliquer leurs politiques y
aurait il se retrouve à sept joueuses de
20 25 25 % maximum ce qui est ce qui
rend compliqué à appliquer une politique
est ce que là aussi il faudrait pas
peut-être alors je sais pas si c'est une
réforme institutionnelle ou non ou une
façon de vivre là politique différemment
mais faire en sorte que des majorités
plus vaste permette au fonds de
gouverner plus que ça ne l'est
aujourd'hui alors oui sur le fond vous
avez raison ça m'inspire deux
observations la première pour signaler
que la logique de l'élection à deux
tours telle qu'elle se pratique en
france pour l'élection présidentielle
c'est celle ci c'est celle que vous avez
décrite au premier tour je choisis au
second tour j'élimine donc ça veut dire
que l'essentiel du vote du second tour
c'est un vote de rejet le vote du
premier tour est un vote d'adhésion mais
la grande majorité du corps électoral au
second tour se prononcent surtout par un
refus un refus de ce qu'il ne veut pas
voir arriver au pouvoir mais la seconde
observation c'est que votre idée de en
quelque sorte de coalition de de
consensus autour de formation politique
plus large susceptible de former une
majorité elle est ce système là il
serait concevable pour les élections
législatives bien entendu alors ce qui
pourrait obliger le président à négocier
avant l'élection met mais ce système là
n'est pas concevable
si vous voulez appliquer strictement à
l'élection présidentielle elle même
alors est ce que nous serions prêts
pour les élections législatives à ce
genre de quelque chose qui ressemblerait
une une coalition à l'allemande par
exemple dans le passé on n'a pas été
loin on cite toujours 1900
1988 1991 michel rocard qui avait avec
l'aide de mitterrand d'ailleurs
nouer des alliances des alliances qui
sont affairés assez fragile mais ça a
finalement pas si mal fonctionné mais il
faut pas oublier que la france n'est pas
la vie politique française n'est pas
fondée sur l'idée de consensus elle est
plutôt
elle est plutôt la vie politique
française elle est plutôt fracturée
alors sans que ça n'a rien de déplorable
ni de désastreux la vie politique
fonctionne sur des fractures à condition
que les gens acceptent de se parler de
débattre je ne crois pas à l'importation
en france d'un modèle de démocratie
consensuelle tel qu'on peut le le voir
ceux pratiqués en allemagne dans
certaines démocraties du nord de
l'europe je crois culturellement là
encore nous n'y sommes pas vraiment prêt
sauf peut-être si la proportionnelle
enfin c'est un autre débat à alger et à
vous à la raison il ya il ya autre chose
si vous parliez justement de cette
tradition française de la fracture la
vème république a été historiquement
vécu comme une fracture entre de la
droite et la gauche une coupure de la
france entre la droite et la gauche 2017
a été un grand changement puisque ni les
deux parties qui avait gouverné jusque
là n'ont pas été présents au deuxième
tour donc c'était c'était c'était un
total changement on entend beaucoup de
voix qui disent il faut revenir à cette
coupure droite gauche
alors d'abord ça pose un problème parce
que la droite on voit bien elle essaye
de revenir la gauche où elle est
tellement divisée qu'on ne voit pas
quelle serait cette coupure droite
gauche mais est ce que vous pensez que
elle et
de dire substantielle à la france une
coupure droite gauche mais est ce que on
est peut-être passé à autre chose avec
l'élection d' emmanuel macron alors
cessé c'est à la fois très complexe et
donc très intéressant ce que vous ce que
vous évoquez plusieurs observations en
premier lieu
je me référais aux travaux de de d'une
collègue qui s'appelle le janine mossuz
lavau qui est professeur émérite
maintenant un lieu paix de paris et qui
en 2020 a publié un bouquin extrêmement
intéressant qui s'appelle le clivage
droite gauche toute une histoire et elle
elle montre elle fait la thèse suivante
c'est que
ce clivage droite gauche il existerait
encore du côté de la demande politique
c'est à dire du côté des électeurs mais
il existerait nettement moins du côté de
l'offre politique c'est à dire de la
classe politique la classe politique
elle serait passée à autre chose là où
le corps électoral lui serait resté sur
ce clivage droite gauche alors ce qu'on
peut dire cette thèse n'est pas
inintéressante ce qu'on peut dire c'est
que il faut néanmoins la nuance et je
suis pas loin de 10 adhérer mais en la
nuançant de manière assez considérable
au regard notamment je cite un second
auteur majeur qu'est marcel gaucher qui
travaillent qui a beaucoup travaillé sur
cette histoire du clivage gauche droite
et qui démontre que ce clivage au fond
depuis 1789 et surtout depuis le 19e
siècle il il a toujours été très relatif
très évolutif beaucoup plus qu'on ne
peut qu on ne peut le dire la droite
d'aujourd'hui n'a presque plus rien à
voir avec ce qu'elle était au 19e siècle
idem pour la gauche et il ya donc
une relativité assez forte finalement y
compris du côté du corps électoral y
compris de ce que janine mossuz lavau
appelle la demande à gauche on admet
aujourd'hui beaucoup plus une sorte de
résignation à l'égard de la
mondialisation à droite j'allais dire de
la droite qui pour moi ma part est
fréquentable la droite parlementaire et
républicaine on admet beaucoup plus
aujourd'hui une forte tolérance à au
sujet des moeurs par exemple au sujet
des sujets sociaux
donc les choses sont beaucoup plus
nuancée quelle qu'elles n'y paraissent
et puis il ya
une autre un autre point qui est relatif
ça c'est du sondage met du sondage très
intéressant sur le sentiment
d'appartenance du côté du corps
électoral à la gauche ou à la droite ce
sentiment d'appartenance il est assez
fort du côté d'une part du parti des
républicains les les sympathisants du
parti des républicains ont une
conscience assez forte d'appartenir à la
droite et l'effort aussi du côté de la
france insoumise les sympathisants de la
france a soumises ont une conscience
assez forte d'appartenance à la gauche
en revanche ce sentiment d'appartenance
est relativement diffus relativement
faible ça n'étonnera personne du côté de
la république en marche des
sympathisants de la république en marche
et beaucoup plus étonnant ce sentiment
est aussi assez largement diffusé à
hauteur d'un tiers 30 à 33% des
sympatisants du côté du rassemblement
national c'est à dire vous avez un tiers
des électeurs du rassemblement national
qui ne se situent pas qui ne se situe ni
à droite ni à gauche ça montre bien que
le duel entre emmanuel macron et marine
le pen échappent à ce cette construction
droite gauche et cette construction de
gauche dans ce dont j'allais dire dans
ce dialogue mais dans ce duel macron le
pen il se reconstruit au fond ce
dialogue autour d'autres clivages alors
d'autres clivages qu'on connaît société
ouverte sociétés fermées souverainistes
ou pro-européen
corps électoral des grandes métropoles
versus électeurs des pères des zones
péri urbaines ou des zones rurales il ya
un auteur anglais ou américains je ne
sais plus qui parle de du clivage entre
jambe n'importe où c'est à dire qu'ils
sont immergés dans la mondialisation et
peuple de quelque part qui sont très
enracinée dans des traditions dans des
cultures dans des lieux et c'est donc en
résumé je crois que ce clivage droite
gauche il produit encore des effets il
est encore malgré tout ancré dans
l'esprit
de beaucoup d'électeurs mais comme dit
edouard philippe la poutre est en train
de travailler et alors ce clivage temps
non pas à s'effacer mais à devenir de
plus en plus réactifs ça c'est une
réalité mais vous savez cette évolution
de toute façon elle est lente et jeu je
je pense qu'il faudra plusieurs grandes
élections plusieurs grands rendez vous
électoraux pour qu'on sache vraiment où
l'on veut un dernier ou peut-être alors
parce que c'est un débat qu'on en entend
beaucoup aujourd'hui sur celui des 500
signatures puisque alors comme toujours
parce que chaque fois il ya beaucoup de
gens qui disent ont du mal à voir les
500 signatures qui finissent toujours
pas quand même par les avoirs de 500
signatures d'élus pour pouvoir se
présenter à la présidence de la
république mais c'est vrai que si
quelqu'un est à plus de 10% des les
sondages ne peut pas se présenter on
peut penser que ça pose pour la
démocratique est ce que vous pensez
qu'il faudrait changer cette ce mode de
sélection au fond des candidats
ce système il sait il est devenu un peu
plus sévère en 1976
1992 de 65 à 74 fallait 106 m donc 500
depuis l'élection présidentielle de 1981
et turcs roi il ya d'autres contraintes
500 signatures dont qui doivent être
obtenus dans le chalet dire dans le
substrat politique locale puisque c'est
ce sont quarante deux mille élus qui
sont habilités à donner leur signature
lors les maires les conseillers
régionaux les conseils départementaux
les parlementaires donc il faut une un
enracinement local et puis il ya des
contraintes aussi assez forte il faut
pas plus de 50 élus par département il
faut 30 départements différents il ya
des contraintes chronologique et puis
depuis 2010 est elle nouvelle contrainte
c'est que le nom des signataires doit
doivent être publiées
alors est-ce que parfois ça justifie et
est-ce qu'il faut revenir sur ce système
où l'amendé ça justifie par le fait que
l'élection présidentielle
n'est pas ne doit pas être alors ça se
discute mais dans l'esprit actuel des
institutions ne doit pas être un forum
de discussion un forum de promotion de
certaines
idéologique certaines idées de certains
mouvements ça n'est pas si vous voulez
la foire politique qui va permettre à
tout un chacun de faire un tour de piste
pour se faire connaître cette campagne
présidentielle à une fonction bien
précise qui lui est assignée c'est de
désigner de concourir à la désignation
du président ça n'est pas ça n'est pas
en soi une mince affaire est-ce qu'il
faut donc à une fonction il ya un côté
fonctionnel qui est attachée à ses à
cette idée des 500 signatures alors
est-ce qu'il faut revenir dessus
je donne mon point de vue je ne le pense
pas est-ce qu'on pourrait l'amendé le
modifier le faire évoluer il ya des
propositions sur ce point il y avait
d'ailleurs une proposition qui avait été
faite par lionel jospin au moment où il
était premier ministre qui serait
de d'aboutir à un parrainage et hybrides
entre des élus d'un côté et des
signatures de citoyens de l'autre ce qui
pourrait essayer ce qui pourrait
contribuer à essayer d'équilibrer les
ces deux pôles mais en tout état de
cause ça n'est pas simple mais sur le
principe en tout cas je suis le moi de
mon point de vue favorable à ce qu'on
maintienne un verrou qui ne me semble
pas un verrou antidémocratique qui
confèrent une fonction bien précise à
cette campagne présidentielle de
concourir donc un élections du premier
personnage de l'état en tout cas jusqu'à
présent avec l'expérience qu'on a ça n'a
jamais empêché quiconque comme candidat
sérieux si je peux dire de se présenter
et même il ya non il ya même des
cordiers juge maria deux candidats
trotskistes à chaque fois que réussit à
redevenir ya quand même bien quand même
une diversité très important quand vous
quand vous regardez aujourd'hui dans la
presse
le nombre de candidats qui se sont
déclarés alors vous vous en avez au au
delà des 12 ou 15 candidats que tout le
monde connaît vous vous en avez derrière
vous en avez ou 25 de personnes
et qui sont et qui se disent candidat
alors évidemment il ya philippot il ya
les drouais l'ancien gilet jaune et
cetera il ya meilleur dire qu'il y en a
il y en a en tout donc ça doit tourner
autour de la quarantaine aujourd'hui
absolument donc voilà ce système des
signatures il introduit quand même une
part de révélations merci infiniment
s'était pas de mensonge et 6 passes
éclairage un plaisir c'était un plaisir
et bonne année et bonne année bonne
année à vous tous merci beaucoup